in this video I want to talk a little
bit about diabetes and the difference
between type 1 and type 2 diabetes so
what is diabetes in a nutshell diabetes
basically just is high blood glucose
levels can be lowered so high blood
glucose levels are bad and they could be
damaging and the reason why they can be
damaging is because glucose will
actually stick on to red blood cells and
affect and interfere with the
circulation of your blood and that can
be particularly damaged damaging to a
lot of blood vessels and of course can
lead to a lot of problems because your
blood has to go everywhere in your body
so no area in your body is safe from
diabetes so what's the difference though
between type 1 and type 2 type 1 is
normally called juvenile onset let me
actually write this in green juvenile
onset and type 2 is usually called adult
onset now those terms are a little bit
or at least can be a little bit
misleading although they're it can be
helpful to remember some small details
but essentially the root difference is
that the problem with type 1 diabetics
is they have a loss of insulin
production they do not produce insulin
type 2 diabetics their problem is a
little bit different they don't have a
problem producing insulin they can
produce it but the they have an
inability there's of the cells to
respond to insulin so they have a
decreased sensitivity to insulin so type
1 diabetics have no insulin type 2
diabetics are insensitive to insulin so
their bodies their cells cannot respond
to the insulin levels even if the
insulin is there so what's the cause of
type 1 diabetes and what's the cause of
type 2 diabetes the cause of type 1
diabetes basically is damage to the
pancreas specifically the cells that
create insulin which are the beta cells
now the the cause can also have
something to do with genetics as well
keep in mind I am kind of simplifying
this overall and I'm not a doctor so
I'm not I'm not an expert all this but I
do have a general idea of what's going
on so the cause like I mentioned is the
damage that pancreas is beta cells so
that they the beta cells can no longer
produce insulin genetics play a role as
well
the cause is often on an autoimmune
disease so if basically if your immune
system attacks your own pancreas
specifically your beta cells and damages
them to a point where you can't create
insulin at all or not enough insulin
then that is a problem so typically this
happens with individuals who are you
know went out when they're pretty young
hence the term juvenile onset usually
people are born with type 1 diabetes or
they're pretty young when they have this
and it's diagnosed pretty early in their
lives whereas type 2 diabetics
it's called adult onset because
generally speaking a diet and lifestyle
have have to do with acquiring type 2
diabetes and again genetics play a role
with type 2 diabetics as well typically
though diets high in sugar high in fat
and high in cholesterol all sort of lead
to type type 2 diabetes and individuals
who are obese typically are more
susceptible to type 2 diabetes hence the
term adult onset because usually people
who get type 2 diabetics diabetes are
diagnosed later in life so what is the
treatment for type 1 diabetics versus
type 2 diabetics generally speaking both
of them are of course encouraged to have
a healthy diet and definitely exercise
this is true not just for diabetic
patients but just all people in general
right you're always want to promote
health by encouraging a healthy diet and
healthy exercise but with type 1
diabetics the treatment is often just
administering insulin and why is that
well type 1 diabetics don't have a
problem with responding to insulin they
just don't produce enough of it or don't
produce it at all so a lot of type 1
diabetics which you'll see is actually
had a buddy of mine who was diabetic and
they basically had an IV connected to
them at all times
so they would like continually
throughout the
a bee on a drip of insulin and their
body would get that insulin that they
needed and they would basically live a
normal life so if if type 1 diabetics
right they just don't have insulin or
don't have enough all they need is
insulin that's what they need to solve
their problem type 2 diabetics can you
administer them insulin generally
speaking no in some cases they might
just need a larger dose of insulin in
order to respond to it because they're
just decreased sensitivity to it but
generally speaking administering insulin
is not the best course of treatment here
what you if you are diabetic or know
someone who's diabetic you might be
familiar with this drug called metformin
so what metformin does is it's a drug
involved essentially in increasing the
sensitivity of cells to insulin so
basically it allows insulin to actually
work or be effective that's one of the
things it does it also has it also
decreases hepatic gluconeogenesis which
basically means that it causes the liver
to stop producing glucose because the
deliverer will produce glucose and start
dumping it into your blood so metformin
sort of inhibits that decreases that so
I hope that was a sort of good general
overview about the difference between
type 1 diabetics and type 2 diabetics I
hope that was a clear or an organized
differentiation between the two hope
that was helpful
I am a tutor if you live in Southern
California feel free to contact me via
email at Mufi University at gmail.com
thank you for watching